Mombasa Wallach yes real quick I'm in
the process of going to Yale New Haven
Hospital number 13 overall okay I missed
I missed that you're going to Yale
University for what in Yale New Haven
Hospital December 13th I'm on dialysis
right now and I was interested in
finding out if I would qualify for the
treatment for disease in which you can't
me okay no why are you going to the
hospital to get it all the royal
examination because here they're not
doing anything funny it's just every day
it's the same thing they're not trying
to do anything new and different how
many okay how many how many Ounces
treatments are you getting a week great
okay how much you ate this morning I
weighed out at 201 79 okay now how are
you
five four okay five for a woman I'd like
to see you a 130 so here about 250
pounds overweight okay anything else any
high blood pressure at night I'm taking
heart on Barry
so my circulation and my high blood
pressure numbers are good okay good all
right so Charmaine yeah here's 179
pounding she's on dialysis okay and so
do you have diabetes Regina
well I don't okay good all right she
don't dialysis for a kidney problems
what would you do for her to support
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries and what would you do for her
for just overall health what I would do
is get around a gluten-free diet and for
those issues I would get around to
healthy brain and heart packs and I
would also get around the ultimate daily
classic and the niacin plus very good
okay char's exactly right so you need to
get rid of all the
Virginia no fried foods no processed
meats with nitrates nitrites absolutely
no oils olive oil coconut oil margins
managed dodging cooking oils no gluten
no wheat Brian oats to maximize
absorption you are which you absorbed
not what to eat and she's exactly right
to health had been in heart packs for
month two full dose everything twice a
day and then the ultimate daily classic
tablets three at breakfast three to
enter time two bottles a month and
they're gonna support healthy blood
flows through blocked arteries which is
usually the problem when people have the
need for dialysis there was nothing
wrong with the kidneys usually but the
kidney blood tests show that the kidneys
aren't filtering blood not because
there's anything wrong with the kidneys
just the dirty blood is not getting in
there because it blocked arteries so the
ultimate daily classic tablets 3:22 day
three breakfast division or time two
bottles a month and two kind of
supplement that she's exactly right it's
your body weight i'd go ahead with two
of the ultimate niacin plus twice a day
two thousand months they are time
release as well as not in flush and so
you're looking at they're going to
support dilation of blood vessels which
lowers blood pressure and and actually
helps blood flows or blocked arteries
but also the plus part of the ultimate
niacin plus is an enzyme called natto
kinase what is natto kinase famous for
Charmaine if if you happen to have blood
clots it will dissolve them
yes it's designed that particular enzyme
is legendary for dissolving blood clots
they use it in emergency rooms you walk
to the emergency room you have symptoms
of blood clot they will inject you with
nano kinase but it works orally as well
as in by injection and we see people who
are able to get the blood flowing you
know a combination of changing their
diet properly and supplementing properly
there's their need for dialysis is
either reduced or eliminated and of
course you have to keep going in and the
blood test will determine how much you
can redo